when you see people working harder than
you what does that do for you Squire me
I see working people working harder than
me I can't imagine that but if I do
surprise me to work harder I mean
glitters not good enough
and great it's not good enough
excellence excellence your names on it
and even if you hadn't have the budget
you needed you gotta take what you have
and do the best you can but you're given
you said to Nick one may look like 20
you got to do it and takes work and
sleep is not something you do we always
like this I had a parents who taught me
ethics that I didn't know they were
teaching at the time I was very very
young and my father managed to say to my
sister and I bill and Evonne always
remember this you're no better than
anybody else but nobody else is better
than you and they said never ask anybody
for anything go get it my father worked
three jobs mother worked two seven days
a week sometimes and they wouldn't take
welfare or social assistance they were
too proud so
I was at a low point in New York City
one time and almost homeless and I
literally was getting high all the time
on different things and I was on the
street I had my hand out I was begging
for money and this older lady came by
one day and she looked a mess and
memcache changed she looked at me as she
walked by I thought she was going to ask
the next person I thought will tap on my
back
the same old lady I said yes ma'am we
got change she looked at my face she
said son do your mama know y'all here
doing this I said no ma'am she shook her
head she just walked away didn't give me
a dime I turned around I sit on the
steps and never beg for money again you
still see her face yes
oh yes they tell me I look likes of what
I walked her she walked two blocks and
took a left and I watched her change my
wife reminding me my parents told me and
I got a college education and I had a
master's degree and blablabla my mother
and father with a second and third grade
and they never asked anybody for
anything I had to carry that legacy on
changed my life